forget it Bruce its Gotham is anyone
even gonna get that I like as a
Chinatown guy i hack with it so Gotham
news came out that Knicks season season
five will be the last and it is believed
I don't think this part is confirmed yet
at least not as of time of recording but
it is it is believed to be the case that
it's going to be a shortened season
probably in the neighborhood of 13
episodes as opposed to the usual I think
22 they do on this show so yeah Gotham
will be coming to a close so I have to
figure out for myself what do I think
about that honestly I think it might be
the best thing for the show I always
worry about shows out staying there
welcome about shows running out of
places to go but doing too well to be
canceled and you know either spinning
their wheels or if it's something that
is trying to have a clear narrative you
know with the steam is really starting
to show that they're making it up as
they go along and there isn't really a
plan you know there there are certain I
you know some of the middle seasons of
lost I stopped watching orphan black
because I couldn't shake that feeling
like they don't know where they're going
with this and I don't want that to
happen to Gotham I'm very glad that it
is getting something on that in that
season four did not end up being the end
I'm very glad for that even though you
know we still got an episode to go but
because I can I want to see what Gotham
pulls out when it knows it's the last
hurrah I want to see that I want to see
what happens there but I do also think
that it's probably a good time for it to
end because I've had fairly mixed
feelings about season four it introduced
some stuff that didn't feel right to me
Ra's al Ghul being the big thing and it
did some other
things that have felt cyclical kind of
Oswald's the big thing on that they keep
having him rise in the underworld and
then fall and then rise and then fall on
their rise and then fall in it it's
become us it's become a cycle that is
frustrating to watch you know he seems
to you know any given season he there
starts at the top and ends at the bottom
or starts at the bottom and ends at the
top sometimes yo-yoing back and forth
over the course of the season in the
middle of it and that kind of cyclical
storytelling that's where it can begin
to feel like the show is just spinning
its wheels until they get notice that
they're canceling that they're being
canceled and then they they figure out a
good end a point so I think that them
getting this out and I meet potential
spoilers for folks who don't know a lot
of like Batman source material so
potential spoilers for the next episode
next episode last episode of season 4 is
called no-man's land which if you if you
don't know from the comics no-man's land
was a seer was a was a storyline that
happened in the wake of a massive
earthquake that effectively cut Gotham
off from the mainland turned it into a
into an island cut off to cut off from
the rest of the country and the the
story of no-man's land was basically the
supervillains battling for territory and
battling with the cops and with Batman
and so you had you know you had things
like the the Gotham PD cutting a deal
with two-face you know to try and work
together to hold back the Joker and you
know you've got Clayface holdin poison
ivy hostage and yeah you did it there
was some some things were better than
others but that was where it went so the
last episode of this season is called
no-man's land so from my money the bombs
that Harvey stopped last episode those
are still gonna go off and we're gonna
get a literally reshaped Gotham for our
last season and then honestly they could
just pull out all the stops you can you
can really figure out where you want to
have these characters end up to set up
Batman
and and you can set that up definitively
and you can have Bruce get his
inspiration for the bats you can have
him you know you can end it with him
designing the suit putting the suit on I
don't know how far you want to take it
but you and with a clear point - he's
made the conclusion he has to become
Batman so you can you can end it at that
point which is really where the show
should end and I I am oddly excited by
this because I think if it it just it
just gotten a standard season five
renewal like you know full season and
maybe they'll get a sixth later we'll
find out I would be nervous I would I
would be worried about where they would
go because it it's gotten hard for the
show to top itself because it's been
it's turned it up past 11 more than a
couple times at this point and it's
really hard to keep going bigger and
like I said it's some things I've
started just to cycle and I I want to
see this show go out with a bang
rather than just Peter out and I think a
shortened 15 episode season five
potentially if they you know plan it out
correctly could go out with a very big
bang and I am yeah normally wouldn't be
excited like a show that I really like
is getting cancelled effectively I mean
it got its renewal but it's getting into
last season it now will end I should be
sad but it feels like this might be a
good time and a good time for them to to
just go all out and give us a big punch
of a finish and I yeah I'm gonna be
excited I'll probably be more melancholy
once we actually get into the season
especially when it gets towards the end
but right now thinking about the news
and sort of initially going ah but then
really something you think about it like
know this I think this is good because
as much as I may love a show I don't
want to see it Dyess
slow drawn-out creative you know death
you know from a lack of ideas or lack of
places to go I want to see it finish
strong and I hope that Gotham will so
those are my thoughts on the
announcement that season 5 of Gotham
will be the last season of Gotham what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down on the comments
let's talk about it there's all that
stuff to do such as like to subscribe
support me on patreon if you want to
support the channel on the show and me
if you don't find me completely annoying
links to all that stuff is down in the
description Twitter podcasts and
t-shirts and so forth so until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]